one of the things i've been saying
during this pseudo scandal involving
republican congresswoman liz cheney is
that we should not forget who liz cheney
is
liz cheney is nothing more than a
republican with whom i disagree on
basically every relevant policy question
and she happens to correctly believe
that joe biden won the election and it
shouldn't be a controversial belief
that is it and it's been disappointing
to see even some on the supposed left
talk about we should stand with liz
cheney
stand with her for what republicans want
a stripper of her leadership role as
they did
let let them figure it out i don't care
to defend liz cheney one way or the
other sure it's funny it's curious to
see the incredible double standard
where the right claims to oppose
so-called cancellation
and yet they cancelled liz cheney's
leadership position for something
that should be uncontroversial which is
trump trump really lost the election
that's it but i have no interest in
defending liz cheney or standing with
liz cheney and case in point
she was interviewed by fox news's brett
baer late last week and on
one issue the 2020 election results she
did a really great thing
she told fox news host bret bayer your
network has to tell the truth
about this issue bret baer didn't like
it lots of people did
that a republican went on fox news and
said you need to tell the truth about
the election let's take a look
i continue to say it though but i
continue to say
but it's it's because it's people of
wyoming who are electing a
congressperson
to fight for them and to fight against
the biden agenda
why wouldn't they say is this the person
that's going to get it done
that's what your colleagues are i'm
going to i'm going to answer the
question
we all have an obligation and i would
say fox news especially
especially fox news has a particular
obligation to make sure people know the
election wasn't stolen
fox news brad i'm going to answer your
question fox news needs to make sure
you're doing the interview i'm answering
the questions we need to make sure
that the american people recognize and
understand
that the election wasn't stolen that we
shouldn't perpetuate the big lie
and that there's real danger you know
i've worked in countries around the
world
okay so it's great right i mean i agree
that's great seeing a republican do that
on fox news that's great stuff
but then and this is the bigger point
brett bayer
asks liz cheney did you vote for joe
biden she's so anti-trump did you vote
for joe biden
and she says not only did she not vote
for joe biden against trump
she would never vote for any democrat
period doesn't matter who it is
take a look and we are going to abide by
the rule of law do you believe
that america is better off with
president biden
than president trump i believe that
president trump's policies which i
supported 93 percent of the time
were much better for america now that
isn't the issue though
the issue is whether or not we abide by
the rule of law
what i did not whether and i would not
and i would not vote for a democrat
ever do not forget who liz cheney
is her depraved immoral party
of which she's a proud member did her
wrong okay they can figure it out we're
not standing with her or them
she may be anti the former guy
anti-trump
but she's still a right winger and a
radical one is that
as left as i am i would never make a
proactive preemptive blanket statement
like i would never vote for a republican
if you give me a specific race and the
republican is better
than the democratic option then i'd vote
for the republican it's that simple the
fact that she's making such a statement
with no caveats about
the quality of the republican and the
quality of the democrat
really shows us what we should have
already known which is liz cheney is no
different
than the trump mccarthy wing of the
party
with some slightly different beliefs but
remember she voted with trump what was
it 92 percent of the time
something like that she's burning a
bridge that's already on fire and we
shouldn't see it as a particularly brave
move or anything like it
i don't take sides in the trumpian civil
war
it's bad for them let the war rage i
have no interest in defending anybody on
either side of it mitt romney anti-trump
republican
didn't vote for trump marched with black
lives matter okay
he was asked okay mr mr romney sir now
that biden's president what next
and he said his priority is preventing
tax increases and preventing socialism
these are not our friends and it's
important not to be tricked into
thinking they are
liz cheney has been silent on the voter
suppression
bills that have been spreading
nationally she's doing nothing to speak
out against it
she just doesn't believe that trump won
she doesn't believe that lie it's not
heroic
and this is why liz cheney shouldn't be
lionized
just for being one republican willing to
tell
one simple truth at the end of the day
she doesn't really want anything to
change
and you heard it from her she would
never vote for any democrat period
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15 percent off
a high quality wristwatch is the perfect
way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my vincero watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
15
off everything in their store and free
shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman